promouvoir l'art et la culture pour tous
en exposant les oeuvres d'associations
mais aussi de particuliers
tel est l'objectif du salon des artistes
artisiens organisé à l'espace bara gaye
le principe c'est vraiment de faire en
sorte qu'on a des artistes sans notre
ville les narcisses bien et qu'on leur
donne la possibilité d'avoir un espace
pour pouvoir exposer c'est important
exposé pour les arcisien et comme chaque
année il ya de plus en plus de monde qui
vient de les regarder et ça nous fait 7
permet à tout le monde de découvrir de
nouveaux artistes
diverses techniques sont en effet
exposés comme les énigmatiques masque de
raku de marie france libère les
sculptures longiligne et délicate de
bernard hubert la charismatique
statuette d'esmeralda de christiane plus
haut ou encore les grands formats de
pascal salin et les impénétrable regard
de ces mystérieux personnage va
retrouver pour des artistes qui sont de
la peinture que ce soit de la sculpture
et dans la peinture on va aller à celle
gras à tout ce qui est dangereux
classique jusqu'à aujourd'hui retrouver
des artistes qui font du pot ce cas et
voir mixer différents différentes formes
en fait de toile pour découvrir ses
multiples techniques de peintures
photographies et sculptures des artistes
arcisien rendez vous à l'espace bar à
quai jusqu'au 16 septembre